as podcast has bad words hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist welcome to episode 132 today
we're gonna talk about experiences and I
thought I could kick things off Ryan I I
couldn't sleep this morning I got up at
2 a.m. and just started writing I
finished this essay I I started this
essay sometime in March right after we
got back from the Australian leg of the
end of our our tour and like it just
sort of sat there and I got I went back
to it this morning and it is called and
it's really about experiences but the
type of experiences that we have this
one's called scrolling is the new
smoking yeah you're eating dinner with a
friend at your favorite restaurant
amid the sounds of utensils and dishes
and mastication you hear the muffled
ring of the mobile phone in your friends
pocket most people wouldn't stop the
conversation to answer their phone in
front of you
even if it was an emergency they would
step away from the table to take the
call why then don't we extend the same
consideration to text messages emails
and tweets look around the next time
you're in line at Chipotle Whole Foods
or Exxon our addictions are showing a
generation ago everyone casually puffed
their cigarettes throughout the day
today indoor smoking seems crazy but
it's been replaced by the captivating
glow of our four inch screens damn
perhaps scrolling is the new smoking now
look around again take in the room
breathe why isn't anybody smiling if the
Telos of our technology is connection
then why do we let our devices create a
smoke screen between us there's been
much talk about building a wall lately
but perhaps we've already built one an
attention barrier between us and the
people in our everyday lives to tear
down this glowing wall
I've been trying something different
lately any time I must respond to a
message at home at the office or at the
local burrito joint I simply say please
excuse me while I step outside and take
this message just like I would if I
needed to make a phone call
or if I decided to take up smoking it
sounds silly at first I know but this
choice forces me to prioritize that
which is urgent versus that which is
important when scrutinized our urgent
tasks are rarely important plus my
friends respect my good manners and they
almost always extend the same courtesy
to me I found that I started doing this
recently even at home like if it's just
me and Becks
I'm like excuse me for a second while I
take this the this message like I would
if it was a phone call or especially
like I mean if I was a smoker which I've
never been but like if I was going to be
a smoker like oh and just oh I'm gonna
light up right here in this triple-a all
of a sudden right
that would seem crazy but the experience
of going to these places I notice it a
lot I was I was at a Chipotle recently
the one on La Brea and Melrose and I was
seated there at one of those sort of
community tables but I was by myself you
know one of the long tables has like six
or eight yes on it and this guy came
home said hey there are no other seats
available guys sit here I said yeah
absolutely goes I went to sit next to
you cuz you look like a human yam and
I'm definitely human he goes I'm sick of
people you're fooling everyone
he said I'm sick of people hmm
and I said what do you mean you're sick
of people he goes look around hmm you're
the only person here smiling and I
looked around and it was true that there
was a whole family at the other
community table all five of them on
their devices at the same time I don't
know what they were doing and I'm I'm
sure that's the modern family man
that's it sadly is and don't get me
wrong I understand there are times where
it's necessary mm-hmm it but but for me
stepping away shows that there's times
that you know what it is necessary I
need to interrupt this experience we're
having because there is something that
happens to be more pressing in the
moment and I don't want to set up that
barrier I don't want to build the wall
between us while we're at Chipotle
eating our burritos I'd rather just step
away for a second and and do what I need
to do because here's the here's the
truth about that the ten times that I'm
itching to reach for my phone and check
the tweet or write down the message or
respond to a text message nine of those
ten times aren't actually important
they're just urgent they feel urgent
it's a faux emergency but yes most
emergencies aren't and and what I found
is that our experiences of life have
changed a little bit so we've got we've
got some questions to to answer today
how about we dive into some of these
these voicemails that we've got let's do
it all right the first one is from Ellen
in Chicago this week I'm moving to New
Orleans to start my master's program I'm
excited to be moving into a new place
into an exciting new city and I'd love
to know what advice you have for moving
to a new city and making sure to not get
caught up in the potential materialistic
experiences that come along with that
move into New Orleans there's a lot of
definitely a lot of experiences that
that she can that she can partake in
down there man I remember we were in New
Orleans it was like non-stop 24 hours
worth of experiences you could partake
in from music to food to concerts
whatever they've got yeah a ton of stuff
going on so so how does she how does she
manage all of this stimulus and all of
these temptations I'm glad to hear that
she said she's excited and not scared or
nervous or whatever cuz shouldn't be
excited exactly and so I know sometimes
some people who are listening to this
they might be moving to a new city or
considering it and and that the thought
of that is terrifying for you but to
realize that quite often the physiology
of tear
or maps on to the same physiology as
excitement and so so keep that in mind
Ellen is moving here to a brand new city
and this could be terrifying but it's an
opportunity for her to be excited so
congratulations for that first question
that I would ask myself if I was moving
there because you're moving there for
your master's program it sounds like so
I don't know are you going to be there
for a long time do you not know what
what is the commitment that you're
giving yourself to right now is it two
years is it ten years is it the rest of
your life and that's gonna help you
identify what is necessary what you need
to bring into your life and you talked
about the materialistic experiences that
come with moving to a new city and so
the first question I'm gonna ask for
myself after I determine how long going
to to be there if I'm gonna be there for
two years then I'm gonna say how much is
enough for that two year period like
what is enough for me and then the next
question I'm gonna ask is okay now
what's really enough so the first thing
when I say what is enough quite often
people will think like okay what do I
need when I move into there the the
chapter and everything that remains
right I start you know filling my new my
new apartment with stuff is like I need
the couch in the end table and the the
sofa and the throat pillows I really
thought they were called throat pillows
at the time right and there's nothing
inherently wrong with any of the stuff
that I was considering buying or the
things I did buy actually the the the
problem was I was buying those because
that's what I was supposed to have
that's not what enough really is what is
enough for you what's going to help you
thrive in your situation so it sounds to
me like you're moving there you're
probably gonna move some stuff with you
but it's also really nice to start with
a clean slate you can go back and listen
to the podcast we did about moving to
Los Angeles moving to this new city and
also the couple podcast we did most
recently the one about decorations we
talked about some of the the home goods
that we filled our own spaces with as
well and and the thing that I had to ask
myself is what is enough for me given
the circumstance that I'm in now what's
enough for me now at age 36 is different
from when I was 28 and I was going to
Ikea and filling my life with all that
other stuff in fact I need a few more
things in my life now because I have a
partner and we have a four-year-old
daughter and so that's a little bit
different the things that are enough for
me you're gonna be different from the
things that are enough for 24-year old
Ellen here so what is really enough for
you what are the things are gonna add
value to life what's gonna serve a
purpose or bring you joy and then Ryan I
know once you've determined that that
what is the bare minimum material things
slowly populate your life with those
material things you don't need all of
them right away think about those things
the real thing to think about here
instead of the new stuff is what are the
experiences that a city has to offer so
when you move to a new place I can think
when we move to to Missoula you
discovered some some new experiences
almost immediately right yeah plenty of
experiences that you know the first
piece of advice I want to give Alan is
make sure she has a clear budget I think
all those things that you talked about
that she some of those things she will
need to bring into her new house she's
got to be clear that she can afford it
and and I am talking about monetarily
here but she's also got to ask other
questions too right can she afford to
conceive Ford to store the item can she
afford to take care of the item like how
much Jake enough apartment to have all
the stuff exactly if she's gonna be
there for only two years then then she
probably doesn't want to overwhelm her
stuff with yeah with with with more
costs than just monetary costs
especially if she's gonna be taking a
master's program that's gonna eat up a
lot of her time and in Missoula man you
know when we moved there I think the
first thing I focused on it was really
finding the right people to hang out
with because I think for so long when I
would find new relationships it was
usually based off of my shitty habits
yeah and when I would build
relationships off of those bad habits
well then guess what I just am
perpetuating all of those bad habits so
when I moved to Missoula I went out of
my way
to make sure to build relationships with
people who I emulated who I wanted to be
like so yeah I was I was in that play
when I first got to mrs. Olaf thanks to
Rebecca Schaeffer and Josh Wagner they
did a really really awesome job of just
helping me grow through this whole
experience of pretty much ad-libbing a
script I mean when I'm when I got when I
got the the callback for the
audition they're like yeah you you've
got the part great come on in we're
gonna start working on the script
tomorrow and I'm like wait what there's
no script and you're the lead role in
this right right so so long story short
I just went out of my way to find good
people I went out on my way to make
myself uncomfortable right and III did
that very very deliberately and there
were certain folks who you know I would
go to build a relationship with and
quickly realize like oh like this might
this might
oh I don't know bring back some of those
bad habits that I was once in or that I
once had in my life yeah I mean the
spark will always want to be there for
us not any of us to have bad habits bad
habits are easy right and so if the
spark is there the last thing that we
want is something that's going to ignite
that around us and and though those
relationships can ignite the bad habits
yes so like there were certain people I
would start to build relationships with
and I was like hey you know what maybe
this isn't gonna be such a good
friendship and that's okay that's kind
of the fun part moving to a new city
right is you get to decide who you hang
out with you get to decide who your
community is you get to decide what what
your new habits are and and really act
on those the the other thing too I want
to warn Ellen about is don't fear that
you're missing out on anything like this
is something that you and I have
definitely talked about before Josh but
I I know when I was in New Orleans we
were only there for a few days in 2014
right but dude I felt like I missed out
on good blues I felt like I missed out
like Mardi Gras was literally happening
like two days the parade was happening
two days after we were there I don't
know if you remember that or not but
they were setting up for when we were
there missed out a Mardi Gras I did not
miss out on Easter's and shrimp and
crawfish I did like eat - my heart was
content but here's the point is that
looking back I didn't really miss out I
mean yeah I would love to go to New
Orleans and like dig some really you
know get some really cool or see some
really cool like original jazz or like
original blues but but you know that is
something that I can always go back and
do if I really really want to Mardi Gras
probably probably glad I didn't get that
that's my 25 year old self would have
been excited but my xxx got going on 37
this year dude I'm not I'm not too too
upset that I missed out on
pretty Gras parade but but the fear of
missing out can be real especially for
Ellen here who was 24 years old so she
might have that fear even more than
someone like me who's you know 15 years
older but uh but Ellen don't don't--i
don't let that stray you from well eh
from following your your values and
beliefs and upholding those but also the
path that you that you've chosen for
your masters your graduate degree don't
let the fear of missing out distract you
from the purpose of why you moved down
to to New Orleans and yeah I agree that
the the the fear of missing out is is
gonna be big especially move into a new
places it's gonna be there's so many
things to do right yeah and the other
thing that comes along with the fear of
missing out is is the the sort of
paralysis of the the paradox of choice
like there's so many options that oh my
god like there I I there are so many
things I could do is ten thousand things
I'm not gonna do any of them because I'm
overwhelmed by it and so what I say is
is pick something know what your
priorities are know why you're there
you're there to get your master's
program that is your that's your
priority right but then what are your
other priorities in life and then fill
your life with the things and the
experiences that augment those
priorities so for me when I first came
to to Los Angeles the museums and
different parks and different programs
or different weekly and monthly
gatherings that things that were
available there were free or inexpensive
or that were well worth the the money we
talked on a previous podcast about going
out to the Holiday Hawk house and
experiencing the the arts and the
culture of a city is a great way to
understand the city and its inhabitants
and also one of the things are gonna
that are going to amplify your health
right yeah yoga or soul cycle or the
Russian bathhouse these are all things
that I think about here and in Los
Angeles where's the healthy food how are
you going to fuel your body so you feel
your mind you do the best you can in in
this master's program the last thing I'm
thinking about here Ryan is this tweet I
got this week from a gal named Hannah
stone she said hey great podcast guys
with the one we did with rich roll a
couple weeks back
and she said Josh at the end of that
episode you mentioned that you loved Los
Angeles you love living in Los Angeles
I'm moving to LA soon I'm curious about
what your favorite areas slash pockets
are how do you think traffic and
commutes fit into minimalism when trying
to find a home base especially in a city
like Los Angeles well what Josh really
meant to say was is that he really
enjoyed Los Angeles that's not gonna
marry it well I love the experience of
Los Angeles right you really loved it
the experience so so I I love the
experiences I don't love the things
themselves right like Los Angeles is a
concept it's not a physical item right I
mean it is technically you know certain
square miles a but but what I mean by
Los Angeles is this nebulous idea of Los
Angeles right but but yeah there isn't a
widget or something called Los Angeles
that I love you're absolutely right
about that I I don't love things that's
what Ryan's getting at here but so my
response to her was I responded with
some pockets that really stand out to me
West Hollywood Venice and a Monica
Pasadena downtown are all great by the
way I forgot to add Silver Lake Echo
Park Los Feliz and in Studio City those
are all really good pockets as well I'm
sure there are many others that I'm
skipping there that I haven't had the
time to experience yet but my advice to
to Hanna
because she asked was spend time
exploring find your tribe or tribes and
the traffic is not that bad if you end
up in a location that suits your needs
and so I think it's important when
you're finding a neighborhood in any
city you're going to like what's the
location that has proximity to what you
need and what you desire when we first
moved were first couple center console
Los Angeles I didn't like it because I
couldn't find the right pockets at first
right and so I think it's about
exploring a little bit explore the city
you have these fresh eyes and by the way
let's say you've lived in Dayton Ohio
your whole life like I did it doesn't
mean you can't explore the city now you
can explore it like you're a tourist and
there are plenty of experiences in the
city you live in right now there are
museums that you've never been to or
haven't been to since you were a kid
there are stadiums and art museums and
festivals that you have not gone to but
if you were a tourist you would show up
why not show up in your own city like
like a tourist with a fresh pair of eyes
and experience your city anew
speaking of festivals I was watching
this video of the most recent Coachella
and this dude was walking through the
crowd videotaping the crowd and it was
there wasn't one person on their cell
phone well I take the back the people
who weren't on their cell phones were
like posing for pictures it was like
it's just funny man very uh very very
telling of the times where Coachella is
this amazing concert that like you know
the folks who put it on really dry and
bring out the best artists are you're
you know Beyonce killed it at Coachella
but it's not really about the experience
it's not about enjoying or loving the
experience right as much as it is about
showing your friends that you were there
yeah and making your friends jealous
that they didn't get to experience what
you did it's a very sort of Stanley
Kubrick movie kind of thing or a David
Foster Wallace novel it's like it's
we're living in a dystopian future it
goes back to the the scrolling is the
new smoking essay which by the way by
the time this podcast comes out it'll be
on the website the minimalists column
slash scroll well yeah that's gonna
share that yeah that absolutely reminded
me of that - man it's it's just
unfortunate that we feel like we have to
I like I just luckily have never felt
this way I could care less about posting
a picture of anything I was just I just
saw Elton John it was one of the most
amazing concerts I've ever seen in my
life
there's nothing on social media about it
I could care less if people knew that I
was or was not a doubt in John I was
there
Mariah was there are two very good
friends were there we had an amazing
time it was an amazing concert I don't
have to a announce it to the world and I
don't have to make other people jealous
that they didn't get to see Elton John
right so I again like I feel lucky that
I don't have this need for for those
ephemeral legs for that for that
attention what sounds to me like what
you're saying but I want
understand it though I want to
understand why people need that and I
don't I don't understand why people need
so much attention why they not only they
need so much attention but they have to
live a life on social media that they
are in fact not living there in the real
life I think I've done a validation
significance and those are the two big
ones like we're two things that really
help with insecurity right so I know
this whole Kanye West things going on
recently you've seen this in the news I
don't even get me started him well know
it but here's here's the beauty of that
what's going on amongst the chaos and
the rubble occasionally there are
glimmers of genius right and there's one
thing he said it was a throwaway line
and the interview he did with
Charlemagne and he said when I see
branding I see insecurity it isn't that
and isn't that what this is it's a and
when he meant is like he in the context
you saw it was like all this displaying
logos like when you see a design of his
own brand we absolutely do actually that
was the genius something he was saying
I'm selling I'm capitalizing on other
people's insecurities yeah that's why my
brands so good well and but when you see
a purse with all these elves and Vees on
a Louis Vuitton purse Oh
what he's saying is you are you are
outwardly displaying the insecurities
it's the same thing as the snapping that
the photo at Coachella or wherever it's
it's look at what I have experienced
accomplished whatever it's not a real
accomplishment it's a it's a proxy for
accomplishment yeah
and and I think the same is true with
this what ultimately what you're saying
is you you live your life for you not
for the appearance that to impress
others you live your life for you not to
impress others yeah and I do like to
share bits of my life and I and I do and
I do that because I know other like
friends and family went to like the
Australian stuff I tried to post some
pictures on Instagram to share with
friends of family so I wasn't texting
and calling you know 20 different people
right when I was when I was on the trip
so I mean I think it definitely does
serve a purpose and I do like to share
bits of my life but you're doing that
too
communicative right not to impress them
sure and I think that's the distinction
that that you want to make here and I
think ultimately if we're go back and
and sort of tie this up in a bow for
Ellen here it's when you've moved to New
Orleans do you yeah it's your life
and and when you're there it's not to
impress other people it's not to show up
and tell them what your job title is or
what your major is live your life for
you and you can be communicative you can
express yourself without having to
impress others that is that's pithy Sean
you can write that down on the minimal
Maxim's Ellen the last piece of advice I
want to give you is don't deprive
yourself if it's not necessary I know
that you're going down there with a
minimalist mindset and you want to spend
as little as possible and you don't
wanna get sucked into any of the
experiences I want to encourage you to
to budget for some of those experiences
if you do have to deprive yourself
because you are in a tight budget and
you have to do that temporarily so great
like we totally encourage you to do that
but don't deprive yourself for the sake
of depriving yourself have fun all right
Ellen I'd love to send you a copy of our
book everything that remains it's my
favorite thing that we have ever created
and it is well it's this five year
journey of me and Ryan leaving the
corporate world or going from the
suit-and-tie corporate guys to becoming
minimalists and ultimately the
minimalist but there's also the story in
there of downsizing when I my marriage
ended my mother died I dealt with my
mother's stuff and had to downsize her
stuff and and went to a different City
and moved all of that around but also I
moved into a smaller apartment and
started downsizing my own life and in
Dayton Ohio and then again we moved to
Missoula toward the end of the book and
that experience of moving across the
country is is in that book as well and a
lot of the lessons learned from that so
Shawn if you could reach out to her send
her an audio book version of that if you
like this podcast you probably like the
audio book or if you're more into
reading books will send you the physical
book or the e-book if you'd like or Josh
will come to your house and read it no
you're not doing that yeah I'll do that
I've been in New Orleans in a while all
right Stephanie is like
as soon as soon as L open Satori Lake
chapter 1 it was a dimly-lit a
conference no no no it's nice to see you
later our identities are shaped by the
costumes we where I'm seated ok
nevermind by the way it's that first
paragraph and everything that remains I
was talking to Jessica our social media
gal Baz so they it's it's the best thing
I've ever written and it makes me
intimidated for the next book or next
thing I'm like in fact I've had four
sort of false starts on books since
writing that book and it's mainly
because of that first page is so good
I'm like oh it's so it's so how am I
gonna do better than that I know what
did you said something to me the other
day when we were it was I think was me
Mariah you and Bex and I figured when I
was talking about it was something about
the special that were filming the
documentary nude the new documentary
special that we've got coming out yeah
and I was like I mean our expectations
are really low our standards are high
yeah our expectations are really low
right and I was kind of talking about
our expectations and you said Ryan I had
this realization the other day uh-huh
that minimalism a documentary about the
important things it might be the best
thing we ever do yeah the most popular
thing and your and your and your and
your your accepting that yeah and you're
okay with that yeah there's no reason
you should not have that attitude with
this and what the next book you're
trying to write no I I totally agree
with you and it you make me may never
write anything as good as that first
page ever again yeah that's true and it
there there's something about about that
writing at the time that I wrote it in
that cabin in the middle of nowhere that
made it sort of like there it was it's
his time capsule and it's and it's it
also feels like when people ask you how
long did it take to write that book I'm
like it took 32 years to write the book
right cuz it's about the experience of
the first 32 years of my life in your
life and and it's this infinitely dense
thing of experience of growing up poor
and then making it in the corporate
world and and the taste and the touch
and the smells and the fields of all of
that
and yeah it was incredibly difficult and
painful to write to and so so sometimes
you have to experience that pain in
order to create something that gorgeous
yeah yeah that's true
our next question is from Stephanie from
parts unknown love that city it's in
Wyoming my friends really like to go out
to eat and I don't really like to spend
the money on that like I tried to if I'm
gonna go out at night I prefer to have a
drink at home instead of going out so
that going out and spending like tiny 12
bucks on a drink and even more than that
when you know when we get food and I try
to do things that are free and I try to
encourage my friends do it too but they
still nevertheless we like to do things
that require money and usually it does
entail gonna have to eat or going to
bars do you have any suggestions of how
I can still spend time with my friends
you know when they all like to go out
and do those things so it's not awkward
when I don't want to go out and do those
things but I'm also not missing out is
the way I can still go out enjoy ie I'm
spending time with them but maybe kind
of have them to just meaning to other
things as well or when we are going to a
restaurant is there another way of
handling that so I think Ryan I think I
think what Stephanie needs to do is she
really has defined the leverage to get
her friends to do something else or and
or she needs to find new friends or she
could do both obviously as well right in
fact I think both is the solution here I
think what she's saying right now if
she's going to her friend say I don't
want to go to bars I don't want to do
this I don't want to do that you don't
want to tell people what you don't want
to do tell them what you do want to do
right and and instead of saying like
well here's the problem here's the
problem here's the problem instead I
want to show up with the solution I know
your friends want to go to bar sometimes
I guess what Ryan likes to go into bars
or he likes going to parties that I
don't like going to and guess what
I don't go to those well Ryan is still
my best friend but when we do hang out I
will propose something that that I know
that we can both enjoy there I'm not
gonna propose things and I don't think
he's going to enjoy hey you want to go
to this really boring thing with me I
might do that occasionally I'm not sure
whether or not you'll like it and I'll
throw it out there I can't think of it
there was one movie we went to be walked
out on I can't think of anything else we
both but we both walked out on that
that's true yeah there's a meditation
seminar I'm going to tonight and so like
there's something like that and and even
then I'm like yeah you might like good
my like going to that you couldn't go to
a planner but that that's the whole
point is instead of saying instead of
saying don't do it tell them what you
can do what you want to do what you
would find value in and why you would
find value in it you get the leverage
well I think you and I can have
meaningful experiences together man it's
because we we really know one another
and because we know each other so well
we we know you know what we can propose
what we cannot propose to do honestly I
can't I mean because we are such good
friends men and like our personalities I
mean we're pretty opposite but for all
intents and purposes like we do have
very similar interests yeah we do have
some there's a lot of overlap on the the
Venn diagram of apps absolutely but but
my point is is that you and I really
respect each other and we really really
look out for one another and so if if
Stephanie if her friends are are like
that where they really respect her and
they want to look out for her I'm sure
that though they will be willing to make
some compromises but I'll tell you what
man like I do still like I'll still go
to a bar just piggybacking off the story
where I was seeing out in John we were
in we were in Las Vegas to see him and
there were a couple nights where the
friends we were with they were you know
hey let's go and grab a drink real quick
and since I'm not drinking nearly is
like I've cut back way on drinking so
I'm not drinking nearly as much I would
just sit there have a club soda or I
would just sit there and have nothing or
have a water and Mariah would do the
same thing yeah we did that well
actually in fact a couple nights on tour
we ran on the Australian tour most of
them I just said no I'm going back to my
hotel room but there were one or two
nights so hey let's hang out and have a
dream
afterward and I would just show up and
have a club soda yeah and there's
nothing wrong with that man I mean
because I was there for my friends I was
there for this concert I was there for
the experience I wasn't there for the
alcohol right I wasn't there for the
food although we did eat some awesome
food but I wasn't there for the food I
was there to have an experience with my
friends so so Stephanie if your friends
are as awesome as I think they are then
you can totally go out with them and
bring a bottle of water and don't do any
don't buy anything when you're not with
them be there with your friends the
alcohol the food whatever it is that
your friends are spending money on that
you don't feel necessary to spend money
on that is not necessary for you and
your friends that have a good time
together and if it is necessary for you
and your friends to have a good time
together well then I'm gonna go back to
what Josh said you might want to find
some new friends that hang out with it
there's a mean that you have to stop
hanging out with these current friends
but that does mean that you might want
to go out and seek communities go to
meetup.com there are plenty of
communities on there and you can find
people who might might align a bit more
with your interest who might align a bit
more with your values and your beliefs
and it's okay to find new friends it's
okay to to split time up with with new
friends um again I'm not saying that you
have to ditch all your current friends
right now
maybe I don't know but there are
certainly ways for you to to not just
find ways to go out where it doesn't
cost money but find people who also want
to go out with you when it isn't gonna
cost a lot of money a couple other ideas
I have to is have you thought about
inviting your friends over to cook like
I know that Mariah and I we've got
friends in Missoula that we used to do
this all the time with where we would
say okay tonight we're gonna have tacos
and Ryan and Mariah because you guys
aren't eating anything and any types of
flour you bring the lettuce wraps and
bring you know your meat of choice and
then they were to sign we would assign
different different greedy --nt stew
different friends to bring those over
and then guess what we get together and
we'd have an amazing time cooking food
together that's certainly an idea that
you can do but but try to think along
those lines Stephanie what what ideas
can you throw out to your friends they
like
they like to get together great how can
you do that in a way that's affordable
for you yeah I think the the thing about
going out to you with your friends to a
bar if all of a sudden you're not
drinking with them and it's a becomes a
shitty experience
you start to realize really quickly like
oh like this isn't actually meaningful
right if you're there only to drink and
all of a sudden you're not drinking and
you're like oh this this isn't what I
thought it was or if the opposite is
true if you show up you're not drinking
and you start to get judged for it then
then then you realize like oh I do need
to find some different friends these
friends aren't the friends I thought
they were and so plan accordingly
the last thing I'll say for you
Stephanie is I think free isn't the goal
here so keep that in mind I know you're
trying to save some money here but free
isn't the goal the best experience is
the goal but money is obviously gonna be
a for the price point is going to be a
part of that last week with TK Coleman
we talked about transactional costs and
so that is gonna be part of the cost but
all these other costs as well the social
costs the the time calls the the driving
to the place a there are all these other
embedded costs that we need to think
about but free isn't the goal I want you
to keep that in mind because if that is
paramount in your mind that that's the
same that's just the same side as the
other side of the spectrum of the person
who was like just trying to spend a
whole bunch of money to impress people
like free isn't the goal here we want to
make sure that we're having a meaningful
experience with whatever we're doing I'd
love to send you a copy of our book
essential it's an essay collection as
150 essays in it but Stephanie for you
the the chapter that really stands out
is the relationships chapter so a bunch
of different essays about relationships
and interactions with the people in our
lives how we can apply the minimalist
mindset to the experiences and and the
people that we experienced those
experiences with all right y'all we'd
love to hear what you have to say so if
you have a comment or a tip about
experiences including advice for any of
our callers today then leave us a
voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine you can also
email a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm we will air our
favorite comments and tips on a future
episode and stay tuned to the end of
this
so for comments and tips as well Ryan
what time is it it's time for our
lightning round where we answer
questions from social media we do indeed
we're on Twitter and Facebook and
Instagram at the minimalists as our
handle there during the lightning round
Ryan and I do our best to each answer a
question with just a short shareable
less than 140 character response we also
put the text to these minimal Maxim's in
the show notes so you can copy and share
our pithy answers on social media if
you'd like and now you can find all of
our pithy quotes in one place
minimal Maxim's calm all right our first
lightning round question is from Erica
is it better to follow the tried and
tested route based on other people's
experiences or is it still better to
take risks and enjoy the experience from
it well my short answer is do what
others do unless you have a good reason
not to and I actually I repurpose this
this is actually from it's not a direct
quote but it's a rewording of one of his
philosophies I'm reading this new book
by what's-his-name's the the 12 rules
for life oh my god Peter and Peterson
Peterson yeah yeah Jordan I was gonna
say
so I've been really fascinated recently
by some of his podcast appearances and
stuff and while I don't agree with
everything he has to say I am much of
what I disagree with my my thoughts are
relatively adjacent to his so it's like
it reminds me of how Newport in a way
our same hair someone like that where I
haven't always agreed with him or even
Rob Bell I don't always agree with
everything but I'm close enough that I'm
like huh he articulates this a lot
better than I'm articulating this
thought or he's obviously thought this
particular subject out a whole lot more
than I have especially when he's talking
about myth but but in this book the the
12 rules for life he is he will put a
link to that in the show notes he talks
about and by the way he is he's going
against the grain very much right now
and a lot of situations some of which I
don't I don't agree with but what I what
I've learned here is that no it there is
a foundation the people do what they do
for a reason so what does Erica
say here tried-and-tested route right
taking the try what's been tried and
tested for a reason that's good we buy
products after they've been tried and
tested I don't want the the the bleach
that hasn't been tried and tested right
or I don't want the food that hasn't
been tried and tested I do want to go
the tried and tested route most of the
time so I do what others do unless
there's a good reason not to do it hmm
if my short answer is this learning from
others mistakes is a good idea
so is learning from other successes but
there's rarely only one way to do
something so what I'm saying is really
if you find that there's a certain way
to do something and other people have
tried it and it hasn't worked there are
examples where yeah you might be able to
make it work there might be you know the
obverse of that is there's a tried and
you know true way of doing something
that has been tested and you try it out
and it fails that's also a possibility
so yes definitely learn from other
people's experiences as much as you can
but don't but don't let that oh don't
let that hold you back from from trying
something that you really feel might
might be something good for you to try
out yeah I think going back to to my
point there on that is do what others do
it's you have a good reason not to me
consumerism is a really good example of
that right like I was steeped in
consumerism throughout my 20s I was
doing what others did but then I found a
good reason not to I was not living a
meaningful life what was my good reason
to pivot away from what most other
people were doing so once you have that
good reason then be willing to take
charge and and be in charge of your own
life you don't have to worry about the
tried-and-tested wilt I think about like
when we started the minimalists I mean
that dude how many minimalism blogs were
there when we started well I didn't know
the time but apparently there was like a
thousand so it's like I knew a five yeah
for sure and I knew that we had like a
different perspective but I mean what in
that first year I just remember like
just seeing like oh my god like I had no
idea it wasn't just you know leo and
Kourtney and Ja
and Colin talking about minimalism right
and and if I would have if I would have
known how many blogs there were before
we started it may have made me
personally trepidatious to really dive
dive into that head first only because
yeah who the hell I look I still look in
the mirror like who the hell are you
and and that's when I would've thought
when we started to the minimalists com
if I don't know there were thousands and
thousands of other minimalist blogs but
but I'm glad I didn't have that
information because it did it did enable
me to you know feel like we really were
onto something and apparently we were
onto something we definitely were it was
about having that perspective but you're
right maybe there were a thousand other
perspectives out there but guess what
there are seven million other
perspectives out there yours is the one
that matters to you so it's best to
refine it by by building upon what
others experiences are what's our next
question our next question is from Senor
Verde mr. green is mr. green alright how
do we better internalize lessons from
past experiences good or bad well I have
a short answer for you a very short
short answer learn then let go I know
for me it's I think of the the David
Foster Wallace line of everything I've
ever let go of has claw marks on it hmm
right and that can be true right like
the we don't actually let go until we're
forced to let go but we can we can
choose to let go everything that we've
picked up we can learn from that
experience we can learn from the path
past but we don't have to we don't have
to continue to hold on to the past
because living in the rearview is a
surefire way to crash yeah I would say
if you wouldn't beat up a loved one over
their past mistakes why would you beat
yourself up I mean I I often when I'm
going to bed at night josh's so to think
of all the embarrassing things I've done
in my life and I'll start to like you
know cringe and like I don't know why
that's when all those stupid
embarrassing memories come into my head
is like right before I'm falling asleep
Wow but it's funny though because what
will happen is I will
I'll be thinking of something start to
feel a little stress or like a little
embarrassed and then fall asleep and
then kind of you know wake back up and
have that feeling of of embarrassment or
that feeling of angst but I can't
remember why yeah and what what is
really hard for me not to do is to sit
there and dig and be like why was it why
am I feeling that I know there was
something I was thinking there was a
past experience I was thinking about
that was making me feel this way what
was that well oh yeah it was that and
then I'll start to relive it all over
again as soon as I find myself starting
to remember trying to remember what had
caused that feeling I will automatically
like start like singing jingle bells or
like start thinking about my favorite
childhood memory or like any because
because it's not it doesn't serve any
purpose at that point in time especially
at night I mean it keeping you from
going to sleep I think I think that the
past memory for at least in my mic for
me it serves a purpose to where I can if
if I ask the question what what have I
learned from that hoping that I don't
repeat the same mistake I was I was
meeting with to question
I was me with Drew the other day the guy
who did the music for our last
documentary and he has this line on his
album I learned a lot of good lessons
here that I choose to forget mmm and I
think that's the problem is quite often
we learn the lesson but then we just set
it aside and keep doing the same dumb
[ __ ] over and over and over yeah it's
like the I know I can stop drinking I've
quit a thousand times before right right
you know it's obviously an old joke but
there's truth in that kind of humor and
let's learn the lesson once or as few
times as possible so they don't have to
keep relearning the lesson and and and
digging it back up we've got one more
question actually we had a lot of
questions around about experiences on on
Twitter and man this was my favorite out
of all of the questions Richard asks are
there any experiences you regret and for
me I was like the perfectly short
question and but also my answer to this
this question is well yeah of course
there are right
but if you want to hear it we're gonna
have a long discussion about this and if
you want to hear our answers to this
question you can listen to this week's
PostScript each week we publish our
PostScript episode over at the
minimalists private podcast and you're
like what the heck is the minimalist
private podcast I thought I was
listening to the minimalist podcast well
the Minerals private podcast is just for
our patreon supporters and that's why it
is private so if you want to support our
show and keep this podcast 100 percent
advertisement free then head on over to
the minimalists comm slash support in
addition to our weekly PostScript
episodes the minimalist private podcast
fee it also includes our monthly ask the
minimalists anything episodes and it
released recordings from some of our
live events we've put out a bunch of
those already and a bunch more of those
to come and oh the entire back catalogue
of of our past a private episode as well
so if you if you've missed out on the
past ones you can sign up and get caught
up over there at the minimalists comm
slash support and once you become a
supporter you also receive a personal
link to our private feed so that it
plays in your regular podcast app you
know the one you're listening to this
podcast too right now so it's Apple
podcasts or overcast or feedly or
wherever you listen to your podcast and
as a patreon supporter you also receive
access to our monthly live stream videos
as well as first access to tickets to
all of our live events before those
tickets are available to the general
public you can find all the details and
good stuff over at the minimalists comm
slash support and here is a snippet from
this week's PostScript episode
[Music]
howdy patreon supporters thank you for
your support we really truly appreciate
it we're here in our new studio thanks
to you and Richard has a question about
experiences for us he says Ryan
are there any experiences you regret he
asked me specifically I got when I was
19 this is what you get patreon you get
you get stuff that Josh and I normally
wouldn't just say in front of our
regular podcast audience all right and
we're back and if you want to hear that
full conversation you can become a
patron over at the minimalists comm okay
now it's time for our added value
portion of the show this is where we
each talk about something that has added
value to our lives
recently Ryan has anything added value
to your life recently
yeah man you briefly mentioned it on the
podcast when we were talking with TK but
uh there's a new album this is new it is
2018 I already told you about it the
leader wise paranoia album Lee DeWyze
so good man I saw him in concert got
just a few months ago the friends we
went to Vegas with yeah they're actually
friends with Lee DeWyze
oh really yeah got to meet his wife and
some out here um I don't know I don't
know where he lives I haven't asked but
that one is so good might be stayin out
here dude you had the boom did you say
your like you said he uses auto-tune
just as good as no I said I said its
auto-tune used appropriately there are
only two artists that use autotune well
it's him and young thug that's he
compared the two that was great but it's
nothing like young no two completely
different genres they just both know how
to use autotune really yeah he did he
did do it really well no it's like the
more and more I listen to it too the
more and more I really enjoy that album
but it continues to grow on me like
first time I heard it I was like wow
this is good but then I listen to it
again and it has just been playing on my
so no speakers in the house like it's
just it's been on repeat man and it is
it gets better each time I listen to it
so I have a few things experiences of
added value to my life recently
and listen to that album is definitely
one experience but the movie which you
have seen Ryan it's just a movie that
has stayed with me and and like it's not
uplifting or anything like that but
sometimes a piece of art just stays with
you you know I'm saying as the movie was
winDriver oh man I know I saw it on the
airplane yeah and what is it what was it
about and well there's a there in
Wyoming he's a hunter I don't want to
give anything away but there's there's a
scene midway through the movie oh yeah
that is that is so visceral and then of
course the the way things play out and
it is it's tied up in a way that I
wouldn't say there is a pretty bow on
top but but it does unravel I would yeah
it's like like an action movie kind of
it's it's hard it's like an action drama
more drama than action yeah it's
definitely drama there's very there's
maybe one action scene in the movie for
sure yeah it was it's one of those
movies were like it can show I know
exactly what scene you're talking about
it can show you the worst side of
humanity yes and and the best side in
the best side and you know what man it
is when I when I saw that movie and it
gave me that visceral feeling at first I
was like I almost regretted that
experience of watching the movie yeah I
was always like this I was almost like
why why would Josh tell me to watch this
movie yeah but but then I was able to
realize like this this this is real life
yeah these are things that happen yeah
and it's it's important to not ignore
those things I guess exactly we can't
just set aside not everything is a rock
movie and Dwayne Johnson is great and
that's uplifting movies and he's just
great Josh Dwayne the rock Johnson is
awesome yes truly awe-inspiring but but
the other side of all inspiring is is
real life and realizing where the
valleys are and we're talking some deep
valleys in this movie and Jeremy Renner
who's the star of the film is absolu
unbelievable I mean how he didn't win an
Oscar for this film III will never know
he did such a great job three other
things really quick there was a music
video is alive well it's at NPR so it's
like live but in studio thing it was
Noah Gunderson his sister Abbie
Gunderson and Phoebe Bridgers and Phoebe
Bridgers is a new artist whose new album
I really love but this video it's a
match up for her song killer and his
song which is called oh the sound and it
is I was watching it with it's like an
eight minute long video music video and
they're just playing these two songs
mashed up together it is gorgeous and
downtrodden but it's an experience of it
was me and back sanella all just
surrounding this laptop watching this
and spoiler alert here Noah Gunderson I
think he got into a fight the night
before there's a bit there's a black eye
and a bandaid on his face oh and it
looks so Noah Gunderson it for those of
you don't know who he is he has some
really great music but we'll put a link
to this and this in this video in the
show notes is NPR video with Noah
Gunderson and Phoebe bridges when he cuz
he's not a popular rock star no but he
looks like the most popular rock star I
have ever seen he's the epitome of he
really is crazy and I've seen him live
so many times and what a great performer
his music it's startling his show it
starts out at the climax and yeah and it
just stays at that climax level yeah
until the very end of it and yeah and
then drops up it's like from the very
beginning he's just like oh it's yeah
he's oh he's definitely a showman very
much yeah the way I would describe me I
would describe him as an acoustic rock
star because and he also plays a lot of
like acoustic shows yeah but it's like
it's almost heavy acoustic is the way I
could describe just saw him in concert
not too long ago yeah I saw him down in
Orange County so it was it did he have
the like all the lights going in the
lasers and so just him and a guitar and
you know it was so cuz you hear the
songs differently that song the sound is
a heavy rock song but when he plays it
on the piano like I felt like balling up
into a fetal position
crying he's that good in fact the way I
would describe it is how jokingly Trent
Dabbs described his music he calls it
heavy mellow and yeah that that's sort
of how Noah Gunderson's music is we
check that video out you will you will
not regret it
two other things really quick stand-up
special from Tom Segura disgraceful it's
had a lot of controversy surrounding it
recently because he's made some jokes
that people in Louisiana were happy
about so sorry Ellen but anytime there's
controversy surrounding something and at
least piques my interest and then I
realized the controversy was for nothing
here but the stand-up comedy special
this is a controversy can I ask her do
you know much it'll ruin the joke I
can't get away as bit all right but to
check it out yeah it's on Netflix check
out disgraceful from Tom Segura it's
hilarious Beck's and I laugh through the
whole thing and then last but not least
Seth Godin has a new podcast they even
listen to it at all
no it's called a Kimbo which means you
have to stand like this with your arm
your hands on your hips like the
Superman pose yeah yeah basically
standing akimbo is standing yeah in the
Superman pose even if you're not
Superman and it is it's it's so Seth
Godin and it's so good I'm Alyssa NARS
yeah and he answers questions at the end
like he at the very end smell he
answered two or three questions within
seven minutes I have no idea why he does
it but he's a master just an hour to do
four but anyway those are the things
that added value to my life recently
I've found a lot of value in all of
those all right let's move on to right
here right now this is where we talk
about what's going on in the lives of
the minimalists well we're headed to
Joshua Tree this weekend we were in
Dayton Ohio last month and we filmed
some stuff for the new documentary
called lesses now we're filming some
more stuff out in Joshua Tree this
weekend and as soon as we have more
details on the minimalists lessons now
documentary we will we'll send that out
to you we'll send it to our email list
first so you can get all the details on
where that's going to be and how it will
be distributed also over on our side
project it's called minimalism life
which you can find over at
minimalism dot life and also I would
encourage you to follow minimal
minimalism life on Instagram it's just
at minimalism life really beautiful
curated collection of photos there at
minimalism life I just published an
essay over there called consumerism is
the new virtue signaling and I'll read
the first paragraph from that will put a
link to it in the show notes as well or
you can just find it at minimalism dot
life there's a lot of talk about
so-called virtue signaling these days
however public expressions to
demonstrate good character aren't new
we've been virtue signaling with our
sparkly new objects for decades it's
common we were talking about a second
ago Ryan it's the the the virtue
signaling quite often of look at this
look how virtuous I am look at the logo
on my bag or look at the the concert I'm
at look I'm at Kochi Coachella let me
sing a car I Drive yeah Ashley no way
yes and that doesn't make any sense to
me why did people want you to know
they're rich well I was just with my
well I was with my friend McGee recently
we were having dinner the other night
he's a he's in real estate and he's from
the Bay Area grew up in the Bay Area and
he gave me this this fascinating while
in his offices in Beverly Hills - so the
people he deals with our in Beverly
Hills and that's not by the way that
isn't not I'm not saying people in
Beverly Hills are bad people NT of
people in Beverly Hills just a very
expensive place to live an expensive
place to live everyone knows the zip
code they're talking yet four or five
six seven thousand dollars a month of
rent it's unbelievable yeah probably a
lot more than that actually as he deals
with oh yeah 45,000 Oh anyway yeah we're
talking very high-end stuff but he's
from the Bay Area and he said yeah I
finally realized the difference between
the Bay Area and because it's most
expensive to live in San Francisco the
moses place in the United States is San
Francisco yeah
and LA is certainly up there so I'm
talking residential yeah per square foot
whatever yeah yeah el is in the top ten
and yeah depending on on what less you
see but San Francisco's the most
yeah San Francisco number one and he
said I realized the difference people in
San Francisco have ten mil
dollars and act like they have one
people in Los Angeles have a million
dollars and act like they have to act
like they have this so Truman but but
again why do people Josh why would I
want someone to think I'm rich somewhat
as if I'm driving down the street in a
nice you know six-figure $100,000 car
yes and Pete and the whole point of that
is so people on the street can look at
me go that guy's rich or the guy next to
me in the car go home I got a nice car
he must be rich why do I want people to
know I'm rich because because of
insecurity and and and I can see that
and thus I want to be significant we all
have a need to be significant it's
important to all of us how we get our
significance is different you might hear
significance from making breakfast for
Mariah in the morning that makes you
feel needed
appreciated accepted significant someone
else it's I literally smaller literally
trying to buy significance I saw a
gold-plated g-wagen outside of our
studio yesterday it was shiny go and it
was it was hilarious
you know many schools and Laos I get
billed for the cost of that car no I
don't but at least cuz I have no idea
how much that car cost but I went and
broke a little piece off and took it
down to the the jeweler down the street
made a hundred thousand dollars right
but but so I'm sorry continue well
consumerism is the original virtue
singlet that's the point
or perhaps value signaling is more
accurate by showing off our fancy new
toys we think we're communicating our
values to the world but we're confusing
our valuables with our values and I'm
gonna cut it off there so you can go and
read the rest of that essay over at
minimalism dot life and what else do we
have right here right now oh I'm
teaching a writing class so you all know
that I teach a four-week writing class
is called how to write better and I know
some of you don't have the time money or
resources or maybe you don't want to
take the investment on of spending all
that that time and attention and also
money to spend on a four week writing
class but twice a year I do a live
two-hour workshop
me and my adjunct professor Sean
mihalick we do a two-hour writing work
sometimes it goes beyond two hours but
it's live you also have access to the
video after after the workshop as well
and it's much much much more affordable
than taking the four-week class and what
I do is I tweeze out the best
ingredients from that four-week writing
class the things that I've learned over
the years about writing about becoming a
best-selling author about starting a
blog about publishing but also about the
the actual writing process the writing
the composition process but also the
editing process and we talked about the
the the best lessons that I've learned
over the years and how you can apply
that to your own writing
it is not a seminar to try to sell you
my four-week class it stands alone on
its own so you will get value out of it
you're not required to take any
additional classes on top of it all so
it's worth the price of admission
because I give you the the I give you
links to the best writing resources that
I've used primarily the four books that
have had the greatest impact on me with
respect to improving my writing and
they're not books that you would think
they're all writing books but it's rid
their not like the the bestseller list
of writing books so the ones that have
worked best for me and I can tell you I
have tried over a hundred writing books
I used to say I've read over a hundred
writing books but I've read the first
chapter of over a hundred writing books
and I've gotten through quite a few of
them I've dozens of them for sure and
some of them have been helpful but the
four that are most helpful for me we go
over those in this writing workshop as
well it's on June 24th this year and you
can sign up for that over at the
minimalists comm slash workshop I opened
that up to three hundred people about
every six months and so those tend to
sell out in advance if you're interested
in checking that out it's June 24th the
minimalists calm slash workshop also if
you're listening to this podcast we have
a video version of the podcast coming
really soon if you want to check that
out head on over to youtube.com slash
the minimalist you can subscribe to that
and as soon as we start the video
podcast you'll be able to to to watch
Ryan's beautiful face pontificate on the
microphone Anna sir come on my hair
before these podcasts one last thing if
you're here let's talk about the show
knows Sean put that in the show notes
pod cam
what about the show notes we emailed the
show notes to you for every episode if
you'd like just head on over to the
minimalists comm in your email address
at the top you'll also get any new
essays that we publish any new news
updates about our documentary but of
course we will never ever send you spam
because spam is disgusting rose Ryan you
got anything else for us I don't know
man do you want to listen to some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners yes indeed let's do it all
right hi my name is Stephanie I am from
Toronto Ontario Canada I want to leave a
comment in regards to the clutter of
post and leave of clutter post for
somebody talking about all those kind of
school papers and will you ever use them
again and saving them etc etc and I
wanted to just share a tool barb is
really the added value to my life as
somebody who is going through grad
school wanting to do a PhD and does need
to kind of refer back to those those
items in those notes Evernote is really
great because you can actually scan skin
party I scan all your items and
chocolates from books you know journal
articles or notes etc and you can import
them into Evernote and you can actually
tag them and you can collaborate and
share your notebooks with colleagues and
stuff and focus does like if you want to
go back in time and review kind of like
something you know that you need to
reference you can go right to your tags
and all your items that are under that
particular category will show up and
official all your notes you can add to
it you can collaborate just a fantastic
tool if you want to move from keeping
all those books and keeping all those
references those reference sheets of
lose papers to a digital form it's out
of a lot of values in my life for I'm
just sharing it with other video
hi my name is Danielle Euler I live in
North Kansas I was calling in reply to
the impulse podcast that you just did
well not just it but the lady who owns
her own small business and she was
wondering how to align people with
minimalism
but also continue to flourish her
business it sounded like she owned a
yarn shop the there's plenty of prisons
and churches that use yarn for different
charity events I know my church does a
prayer shawl and that some prisons
locally these blankets for small
children in hospitals and that's a way
if they would donate their yarn to give
them a discount and that can also be
something she gives back to her
community hello this is Morris Bradley
Watson calling out of Tampa Florida and
I just wanted to bring up a line of
thought in regards to the selling part
of decluttering when it comes to
minimalism the first half is a list of
price points to consider when selling
some of your unused stuff and the second
half is the philosophy behind why
letting go is okay even when you may not
be 100% happy with it so here are five
price points to remember and consider
when reselling an item one the price you
paid for it sans tax to the used price
sans tax which is always half the
original price this is what most people
want out of their items but it's not
what they'll always get three the market
price for similar items for the price
the consumer wants to pay for the item
and five the price you want or will
settle for when it comes to the item one
thing to remember is that you don't
actually own anything that may be a
difficult concept to grasp but let me
explain everything you buy is a
remaining lifetime rental
meaning that when you are no longer here
your lease is up and your stuff is not
coming with you
where those from there is up for you to
determine while you're still here
but let's say you get a brand-new couch
for five hundred dollars and use it for
five years you may not get two fifty out
of it you may only get fifty to a
hundred dollars but even if that you
have the experience of owning that couch
for better or worse in if you discount
the amount you resold the couch for you
can count that as how much you initially
paid for it and if you do feel bad about
spending as much as you did initially
taking off that $100 can help you feel
so much better so way you say if this is
a remaining lifetime rental what happens
when I break the lease and I resell it
now that's actually a really fun part
because most times when you break a
lease you have to pay a fee but in this
scenario you're actually getting paid
but anyway I found that looking at
things this way has really helped me to
clutter and let go I hope it helps
everyone - all right Joe that's it for
this episode if you have a question for
the minimalists give us a call for zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
you can also email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists comm and if
you leave here with just one message we
hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listen y'all we'll see you
next time
and minimalists